hi I'm Peter Hopkins president and
co-founder big thing calm and it is my
pleasure to welcome best-selling author
Richard Florida for a live interview
today Richard is far and away one of the
world's leading experts on business and
business sociology and today we're going
to talk about his research into the
creative class which is the emergent
group of people who are really driving
economic growth both in the US North
America and around the world Richard
great to have you it's great to be here
Peter yeah so let's start by framing for
the audience what is the creative class
well as you said in your kind intro it's
it's sort of the driving force of
innovation and economic growth and and
before I came up with this idea I mean
there was a lot of really smart people
thinking about this change from an
industrial society you know an old blue
collar manufacturing driven steel and
autos kind of economy to a post
industrial economy and people like Dan
Bell the great sociologist at Columbia
and then at Harvard wrote a lot about
this and then of course Peter Drucker
you know probably one of the greatest
bad probably the greatest management
thinking of all time kind of dubbed this
group of people him and a guy named
Fritz malcham in the 50s dubbed this
group of people knowledge workers and
the idea was that people work with
knowledge they accumulate knowledge
economists talked about developing
education in human capital and i was
living in pittsburgh at the time
teaching at Carnegie Mellon and I was
looking at just like you and others
developments in the internet and
technology and I noted this kind of
thing with content and software and then
I began to see the role of arts and
music and I remember I remember going to
England one time and this guy asked me a
question about software development and
biotech clusters I look at him I said
who are the richest people in England
always like that's Paul McCartney and
Mick Jagger so I said there's something
with arts and music and entertainment
and something with technology something
with knowledge workers what do they all
have in common and one day I was reading
some psychology and they were talking
about human creativity this guy Rob
sternberg wrote if you're an
entrepreneur or a business leader an
artist or a musician to design something
like that you're a creative person I
said oh my god maybe it's not just a not
llege class or a post-industrial class
maybe this thing that links these people
together like the blue collar worker
used physical labor in the factory maybe
the thing that links these people
together is their creativity so we went
back and we counted them with a great
group of researches at Carnegie Mellon
and we first counted them across cities
and then we said we're going to go back
100 years and count this group of people
and what we saw is that over the past
hundred years but certainly since 1980
this group was really expanding and just
to give folks the numbers between 1980
and today even with the crisis we had to
20 million new jobs in the creative
sector of the economy that science
technology arts entertainment a
filmmaking design and then the knowledge
workers right healthcare practitioners
lawyers those financial people who cause
part of this problem and in the United
States that's about a third of the
workforce more or less and in this
creative class even though they make up
a third of the workforce if you add up
all the wages and salaries we pay in the
in the united states and you divide it
into three groups right the
manufacturing working class the people
who do services lower end services you
know work weight on you in restaurants
sell your clothes take care your house
and then the creative class the creative
class already accounts for more than
fifty percent and the other thing just
wrote folks watching we've actually
tracked the unemployment situation and
it's quite devastating in some respect
while the overall US unemployment rate
is ten percent and and while
manufacturing workers have unemployment
rates fifteen percent and in some parts
like extraction and construction
twenty-five percent the creative class
is about five percent so the creative
class has never seen right great swings
I mean that's up from do percent before
it's never seen these great volatility
and slings that really devastate
manufacturing and and so I think as we
come out of this crisis we're going to
gency that this group is more stable
this group of jobs is more stable and
they're going to grow again so let's key
off that you have an idea that you've
called the creative economic revolution
and that really ties in to this notion
of the you know this class that is
helping to drive prosperity what is
actually happening to the economy as you
see it that is enabling the the rise of
this class of people actually think
behind the crisis is the crisis is kind
of the inflection point or the
transformation point you know if you
look back at the two previous crises and
and I'm actually writing a book on this
it's called the great reset hopefully
you'll invite me back to talk about how
when it comes out it
I met but if you look back on previous
crises they've always been associated
with the rise of new economic systems so
the crisis is 1873 was associated with
the rise of you know the first
Industrial Revolution and it gave rise
to the second the crisis in the 1930s
was the rise of the Second Industrial
Revolution in these big steel companies
and auto companies and then we figured
out how to make the society work this is
really a crisis not just the financial
markets and wanted spending and too much
credit it's a tectonic crisis that's
associated with the rise of a new
economic order and what we were doing is
because we didn't know how to invest in
it we were speculating like while and
money was flowing into real estate so
the creative economic revolution has
really been going on in my view since
the 60s and and it's funny because I
went back and looked at this and and
folks might not know this but what I
really wanted to be in life was a guitar
player so all my childhood I spent
playing guitar and and trying to sound
like Jimi Hendrix or Jeff Bacharach with
some degree of non success but in the
60s we saw all of this creative
revolution weather and even before that
jazz and the 54 but the beat revolution
and then the sixties thing happening in
New York and I just read the fabulous
book on unworn the velvet underground so
you know you can see this stuff building
up as people are tired of and kind of
blanching at the strictures of the old
organization man society and its kind of
you know it's kind of our world
fascinated by madman I think you know
you see this transformation this kind of
pivot point right running through as
madmen develops and this creative thing
emerging but people don't know what to
do and so the one way I kind of view the
1960s is this giant temper tantrum right
creative people just saying I'm not
going to take it anymore mom and dad I
want to grow my hair long I want to grow
up beer and I want to go to California I
want to listen to new kind of music this
explosion in heart but was it really
hinged to the economy in the book I said
it Woodstock wasn't a signal event of
the creative revolution Silicon Valley
is and so I think what happened almost
at the same time is these people who
were tired of working in the big
companies innovators some people working
at IBM in general electric Bell Labs
said no we have all the school stuff we
want to make all this interesting stuff
we want to make the company's very
bureaucratic it's not paying attention
to
somehow they found their way out to the
San Francisco Bay Area and began to
build these enterprises that they owned
in control right they begin to devise
new structures and new forms and
actually Peter my entire early research
career but well before I came to any
ideas of the creative class was trying
to figure out what Silicon Valley was I
wrote a book in 1990 about this called
the brakes or illusion in any event I
think those structures began to take
hold and this new group of people who
had the ideas began to be seen as more
economically valuable and what's
happened over the past 20 or 30 years as
manufacturing has been offshored an
outsourced and was moved to the bricks
but particularly China I think in the
advanced countries like the United
States or canned or Scandinavian
Northern Europe this creative input this
idea input this mental labor has become
more important so I see this shift as
big as it fundamental as the shift you
know that Marx wrote about when we move
from a few Tyler agricultural society to
a modern industrial economy and society
I see this shift kind of the same way
we're moving from an older industrial
society where value was created by
physical labor and raw materials to a
new kind of society and economy we're
valued more I mean more materials in
physical labor in agricultural are still
important we need to eat and drive
things and we need homes but this mental
value-added this creative labor is
becoming more important so that's why I
think this is a big revolution on the
order of the transformation of the
transformation from an agrarian society
to an industrial economy in society you
know and I do a lot of interviews and I
think that this actually is one of the
most powerful forces at work today and
particularly from the perspective of the
you know displaced manufacturing worker
somebody working on an assembly line
they're looking at a huge divine between
you know the world that gave them
prosperity in this new world guess the
question is if you are one of those
people what is your future is create
creativity in these new pursuits
something that they can ultimately learn
and buy into or what becomes of them in
this in this new world that you
described well it's if you're if you're
one of those folks it's terrifying you
know I lived in Pittsburgh for nearly 20
years if you're a person who had a great
job in a steel mill and then you get
this placed when you're 35 or 40 or 50
my wife Roni who's here just in here the
room folks she's from
a tour de troit and we'll go back we own
factory for thanksgiving will go back
there for the Christmas holiday I mean
the devastation that's happened to
people who grew up thinking they had
fabulous stable jobs with the big three
is truly horrific but I think I think as
a society we've got to understand this
shift you know a hundred years ago if we
were sitting here we wouldn't be in a
television studio but if we were sitting
around talking we would have been
terrified that agricultural jobs were
going away and you know if you were
faced with the prospect of losing your
farm or being forced off the farm and
having the move to one of these growing
industrial cities people were terrified
and in the debate was where are these
people going to work if there's no jobs
on the farm anymore and these automated
factories are so productive but we
invented and I guess I'm an optimist in
this sense throughout human history
we've always invented new ways of
working new divisions of labor so my
hope is that we can do it again what I
worry about them when I really worry
about like thinking about the Obama jobs
summit and the conversation about
employment most of that conversation is
either about government created
employment which is a good stop get it
can work for a while the WPA and all of
that in the depression created jobs for
a while or it's about how do we protect
these manufacturing jobs which are good
jobs my dad worked in a factory all of
his life and I talked about in my books
and maybe people watching but my dad my
dad got a job at 13 he actually had to
leave school in the seventh grade in
Newark because he had to go to work his
brothers and sisters had to go to work
my grandpa had work and my grandma
worked in bakery took nine people to
make a family wage and my dad worked in
an eye glass factory in the down next
section of Newark the ironbound section
is called victory optical this giant
brick building and I remember my dad
telling me when I was a little boy he
said rich when I started working that
factory in 1934 1935 I had a really
crappy job I mean I made low wage I had
virtually no benefits we worked long
shifts and remember people used the boom
own manufacturing work is that terrible
dirty dangerous we in Blake called
factory satanic satanic Mills my dad
said but when I came back he was a he he
enlisted in World War two and he was an
infantry soldier in the great battles
d-day and all of that storming the
beaches when I came back from World War
two he said rich something happened to
my
job it became a good job now obviously
there was a unions that helped to do
this and collective bargaining and and
government into the Wagner Act that
Franklin Roosevelt past and occupational
health and safety but my dad said my bad
job became a good job and so what we've
been working on actually in our
Institute and so glad you can come up to
Toronto where we live now what the City
of Toronto has been pioneering and I
think I think we're going to help define
this turf we saw mention that a third of
the jobs are in the creative class about
twenty percent of jobs are in blue
collar forty five percent of jobs
forty-five percent of all jobs are the
service jobs but we talk the retail jobs
the shop jobs the restaurant jobs the
manicurist the haircutters the makeup
people those jobs pay the wheat least
they have the most tenuous circumstance
so one of the things we're trying to do
right here in Toronto and with the city
and city workers and city government and
folks here but also I think needs to be
talked about Morris how do we make that
group of service jobs good high-paying
jobs equivalent to the fact you know
lower skill like the factory job was but
how do we make those jobs more
innovative how do we get people involved
like they were in the factors and proven
correct it and how do we raise pay
that's one of the key things were
working on and that's the kind of job
somebody who worked in an auto plant if
it was high paying and it was a good job
not if it's at 10 buck an hour job but
it was a good job with a career
possession that's the kind of job they
could naturally slip over to so let's
focus on that for a minute it's a very
interesting concept elevating the
restaurant worker of the hair stylist to
you know a higher plane in society that
would seem to have to involve some
greater investment of value you know you
can just wave a magic wand and make the
mcdonald's worker you know a high level
of a part of the economy what can be
done to make them more value additive
and produce more relative to their their
inputs well you means one thing that
we're going to have to pay more for our
burgers and you know at the end of the
day it's worth it you know we Pendle to
spend a lot of money for a car we spend
a lot of money even for a television set
or a computer now they've come down in
price we spent a lot of money for the
clothes we wear and then you know we
don't want to spend a lot of money for
the food we put into our body or what
about the person who takes carrier alley
parent or your kid
I mean to me it's we're gonna have to
pay more for that so as a society we're
going to have to pay more okay people
might not like that but if we want to
elevate jobs and create livelihoods for
people the other thing that we see
happening and we're trying to organize
this some of these companies to come in
boy oh boy I wish Obama would do this
this would be the job summit I actually
looked at cuz I'm a geek I looked at the
best places to work institute their
research on the best places to work in
the US economy and folks can go to it
they'll see that I have the wrong names
but you know you get all kinds of
interesting tech companies on that list
the SAS institute which I actually did a
case study in the North Carolina
genentech all of these cool names that
you know Apple the other companies and
some consulting firms right the other
companies on that list are like Zappos
wegmans Whole Foods container store what
those companies are doing is actually
they're viewing their workers as a
source of well creativity innovation and
they're taking a page from a company
like Toyota which said you know we're
going to view our workers not so much as
a liability we're going to organize them
in teams we're going to tap into their
brain power and the guy who really
challenged me on this when he was CEO of
best buy was Brad Anderson memory came
and we had this roundtable discussion in
washington DC at the gallup organization
and brad was saying you know in my best
buy store there's not much i can do to
improve performance I mean we sell the
same TVs we sell the same stereo sets we
sell the same appliances and we have a
kind of standard process he said the
only way I could really make my stores
better is by getting the intelligence of
my employees so he started to actually
do what Toyota does challenge the
workers to actually come up with
suggestions and continuous improvement
and you know and it would be simple they
would like figure out a way to move a
display to get more sales I remember one
which was just blew me away they were
trying to figure out why they weren't
selling in ethnic neighborhoods in LA
and the one kid on the floor said well
you're not having ads and it's not only
Spanish but Vietnamese so so he started
to write the ads now it's simple stuff
like that but that increases value and
what we've been unpacking in our work is
is the skill sets that really increased
value in the workplace and there are
three kinds of skills in the workplace
really there's physical skills we
actually pay a lot for physical skill in
the United States or Canada and it does
generate that much return there are two
other kind of skills that really matter
in the workplace one is the obvious one
in a knowledge economy cognitive skill
so the more brain power you have the
team and you engage the better but the
other one that actually pays more is
what we called social skills and by
social skills I don't mean just being
friendly and extroverted and a good
bartender it's actually and you'll know
this in the stuff you discuss on this
program it's the ability to build teams
to motivate people to get other people
to be part of your cause of your mission
so I think if we could start to upgrade
services with more cognitive skill but
not just more cognitive skill more of
this social skill and I actually think
from a business point of view this is
the great low hanging fruit the creative
economy is humming along art factories
are optimized now we can do better and
you know more robots but the low-hanging
fruit in our economy is really bringing
the service is the low end services into
the 21st century and so that's what I'd
like to see happen and I think I think
in terms of job creation its millions
upon millions of Americans work in that
sector it's highly insecure it's
low-paying it's the sector if we want if
we want to say we're going to build a
backbone again of a lot of jobs it's the
only place we have to look unless we
just say you know we're gonna have a
crappy split unequal economy and I'm not
willing I'm not willing to relent to
that right right right yet now you I'm
curious other models you mentioned best
buy but are there models that have been
developed that actually are able to
assign value to the work of service
workers and actually cut them into some
of the overarching value that they can
generate through these things or is it
simply you know right now just kind of
casual and haphazard it's very casual
and haphazard you know we've been we've
been looking at the four seasons it was
started here in Toronto it's I mean
obviously a luxury brand but it's the
kind of brand it depends on allegiance
of its customer and and it really has
worked hard to end all the other thing
is promotion from within I mean that's a
key thing you might start as a low level
person but but the ones that work always
just like Toyota its promotion from
within so you may start at the lowest
occupation but you can work your way up
I think now we're in the same situation
is kind of Frederick Taylor you know
sitting there in the 1880s and 90s and
and a few manufacturing companies were
experimenting with time and motion
studies and scientific management
were certainly not where Henry Ford was
when Henry Ford said we can add the
assembly line and have an organized
production system so we're very early
into this and I think the key right now
and what we're trying to do at our
Institute is really array a set of best
practices and we had a meeting last week
and we said you know we've got to go at
this just the way people studied high
performance of quality manufacturing
we've got to figure out what those best
practices are in the workforce with
regard to pay and benefits and then we
have to see to what degree their
diffusing and how they work together but
I think we're extremely early on the
companies i would look at again Whole
Foods engaging its workers to a certain
degree starbucks I mean which is a
pretty big company container store is
another one that's done a lot of this
and and we're going to have to figure
out models Zappos online figure out
models that go beyond that and push it I
I don't think it's in academics you know
who's going to leave this I think this
is a very much in action strategy
project where you know and maybe the
better example is agricultural extension
right how they began in the farm to move
new technology on to the farm and then
what we used to call manufacturing
extension back in the 80s when they so
oh my god manufacturing is becoming
leaner and more quality as we identify
those practices an effort to defuse them
and to make people understand you don't
have to treat workers you shouldn't
ethically treat workers like crap but in
your grocery store or in your mom and
pop shop or in your hotel operation if
you stop treating workers like a cost
reliability you start treating workers
as an asset you invest in them you
upgrade their capabilities you can get
more productivity innovation that's
where I think we have to go now is there
something fanciful about this notion in
that at the very moment where you're
seeing contraction the consumer economy
that we have are now potentially relying
on consumption and treating workers
better and paying them more as a you
know as a ballast for the rest of the
economy well isn't this the great
problem in every crisis isn't this what
Keynes wrote about I mean the nature of
a crisis is a big race to the bottom
right that's what a crisis is about
everybody says oh my god I've got to cut
costs I got I've got to get my balance
sheet in order and n so canes and others
others in the United States businessmen
were worried about oh my god how are we
going to create demand this ephemeral
thing called demand and what they
quickly figured out is the only way
you're going to create demand is by
raising the incomes of workers if you
kept the workers incomes low when you
pay them like crap and yet and you gave
a minimum wage or below subset it's late
in the factory how do you create that
demand that we're going to buy the cars
and houses with so they put a lot of
effort into that naturally I mean in the
United States not only the Keynesian
thing but the United States move pretty
close we actually had a full employment
bill in the House and the Senate in the
night late 1940s and then fortunately
the machine kicked into action that got
table now in other countries in
Scandinavian Northern Europe and Japan
that became a reality but here it gots
got all the United States got scuttle
and the idea was that we can create
demand and and one of the things we
create that demand by building roads by
building houses by building appliances
it became a cycle when I was a younger
person we used to talk about for dizzam
a fancy concept for not only for this
mass production right what the theorists
at the time arguing not only do you have
this mass production system with
assembly lines and steel mills and car
factories pumping this stuff out you had
to build not only a forest economy you
had to build a forwarded society well
the Florida society required higher
wages Henry Ford's great idea that oh my
god these workers need to make 5 bucks a
day too so they can buy a car and you
need to have institutions right
governmental institutions of social
welfare state infrastructure investment
mortgage banking that could make it
affordable to buy a house we don't even
have that conversation now all we're
thinking about is how do we cut the cost
how do we get the economy back on track
and then the silliness of like trying to
reflate the old for this thing I mean I
just I like slam my head against my best
yeah we're going to do a cash for
clunker we're going to do a cash for
appliances we're going to we're going to
you know have everybody redo their
mortgage so they can buy another house
they can't afford or walk away from this
house and buy another house one of the
things that we're going to have to
figure out is how to be and this is a
big task this is a task like we faced in
the 19th century what kind of society do
we have to build if we're going to
uncork this tremendous creative and
productive potential this is not just a
task of you know Keynesian demand
management and fixing the economy and
making sure the bubble isn't blow this
is a task of building a whole new social
order and what I'm what I like that
we're having this conversation but what
I'm scared about is in the halls of Pat
in the car there's a power
as far as I can see around the world
this conversation isn't going on and
that conversation did go on in the
United States and in England and in
other places in the 1880s it didn't go
on in the 1930s and 40s for some and
maybe it's because we're so early you
know which this thing just happened a
year ago maybe it's because it's so
early and we think we can just brush it
aside but sooner or later i hope that
conversation emerges how do we build a
society which is values the creativity
of everyone creates markets for that
creativity creates good jobs for people
and is functional now I mean it's
striking how eerily silent it is across
so many domains what this is should be
in front of mine one area is education
this is not a conversation at least to
my knowledge we interview a lot of
Education thought leaders where this is
taking place in terms of the curricula
in terms of how students are taught to
think about their role in the larger
macro economy my question for you is for
viewers out there who are listening to
this and wondering where do I fit in
what would be your counsel with regard
to how they self prepare how they train
themselves outside of a system that is
perhaps not ready to do it for them what
are the skills that they need to develop
whether to be a value additive service
worker on one end or you know a hyper
intellectual or knowledge-driven
creative work well the interesting thing
about service work now that you say it
is a lot of the creative class is moving
into this work and I think that's why
you see such a revolution then I mean
you know this fellow Matt craft Crawford
who sometimes criticizes me I have no
beef with the guy who says he left his
ph.d and went back to open his
motorcycle shop well he had the skills
and the capability to make a great
motorcycle shop you see so many members
of the of the creative class going into
you know home repair or you know or food
the whole revolution that's going on in
food and restaurants and organic
products in Canada where we live this
whole thing with ice wine and upgrading
of ice wine so you see the members of
the creative class going into this stuff
and saying oh that's really interesting
in terms of skills I think our work has
helped us identify this I think in the
United States and Canada and Europe
we've all been in an age
we've all been told be smart that's what
my parents said my dad said I work in
the factory rich and they sent me to
Catholic school Queen of Peace of all
places boys high school in north
arlington New Jersey in the heart of
sopranos country and what why they send
us their two boys Richard and Robert
they wanted us have a good education
that was the ticket to upward mobility
and you got a career so we went to
rutgers college got garden state
scholarships and figured out I I majored
in urban planning and figured out a kind
it was the way into the economy I think
now though that's not enough of course
an education is helpful and our work
suggested the cognitive skills the
knowledge skills are only part of it
actually it's the social skills that
really matter and and if I had to be
really blunt and give kind of business
advice the one thing that we don't teach
I teach in a business school but one
thing that we don't teach in the
business school that we don't teach in
schools not only entrepreneurship we
don't teach people how to sell it's been
the hardest thing I've ever had to learn
how do you sell how do you pitch a book
project how do you and you know this to
you had to build a company we have kids
and I try to hire people and they say
I'll come work for you but I don't want
to sell well I mean I hate to say it in
this kind of economy that we have this
fragmented would then being calls a free
agent economy which I think can be
better for lots of people if we have the
right social supports and right benefit
systems we have to set we have to sell
more so those the social skills the team
building the selling the other part it
was education and we don't know more
about this but I always hated school
from day one I never liked it I never
felt it was an education system I felt
it was in education school maybe it's
because I went with nuns and Ida scars
to prove it have that effect yeah yeah
but I've been doing but I never liked it
in college I never went to class and you
know what's interesting about this you
know and I hung out with my friends and
we talked about interesting stuff and we
have this you know kind of wide-ranging
seminar over beers at night but you know
whether it's steve jobs are Michael Dell
or Bill Gates people who are far more
business savvy than I'll ever be or most
of us ninety-nine point nine percent of
us all of them dropped out of school so
that's telling me that something in the
system is broken and I think one of the
great things about technology and I
don't want to overblow technology but we
both love it I think the technology
enables kids to learn without having to
be stuck in these many stultifying
places called schools
and if we look at learning less as real
estate as you know send the kid to a
school and more as development I mean
Ken Robinson nails this you know when he
when he talks about it like ninety-nine
percent of three-year-old score is
creative they go to school for a few
years it's down to 50 by the time
they're teenagers it's 10 and by the
time they're my age it's like one
percent I forgetting statistics but
there's something like that so I think
we have to build institutions not of
education but of learning and those are
going to have to be human centered and
individual and I think the technology
gives us a chance but you know when Bill
Gates said the school system is broken
he's right when Peter Drucker said I can
the research university will not survive
the transition to the knowledge-based
capitalism the way we deliver learning
is very broken and very in unhuman so it
seems to me that's got to be a first
principle we've got to somehow you know
it's really interesting in the 1800's we
built a system of mass public education
1850s and 60s in the 1890s we started to
really work on the colleges in the
universities and build them up after the
war we had the GI Bill and we made
education available to working-class
people like me my dad went to 75
grandfather none my dad 7th grade I have
a university education I think what we
have to do now to remake this system is
bigger than all of that combined and
here we think about tweaking the schools
at the margin if we're really going to
build this kind of creative society we
have to completely reinvent the way you
live beings develop and learn you raise
it a really epic point and you know
we've seen this across so many areas the
challenge of actually remaking
institutions which is actually a
different project than building them in
the first place because you've got to
uproot a lot of existing and entrenched
interests and reteach a lot of ingrained
practices where do you see us in that
process particularly with respect to
education and how it cultivates
creativity have it has a big gun is
there any model or are we literally at
you know to start him it's funny if you
look beneath all of my writing and I
often say I'm a much better verbal I try
to write but I'm not a great writer and
it's hard for me and I'm in academic so
that makes it worse I'm an okay talker
so all of my work really is about this
question of institutional redesign I
mean from the beginning of my work in
the in the late 1890s and 1990s was
always about institutional
design and I think our institutions the
mass production institutions the fortis
institutions have been broken now for a
generation and yet nobody wants to
confront it and I don't understand why
you know manzer Olson wrote the real key
to the decline of Nations was when these
institutions become he called it
sclerotic institutional sclerosis he
said why regions decline why nations
decline why companies decline is very
simple these institutions are built
they're great for the time they're built
they work like clockwork and then over
time as the environment changes or they
just become more rigid in bureaucratic
and sclerotic and he said that sometimes
why history moves from the Netherlands
to England to the United States around
for the east coast to the west coast and
now some say I think it's early
Anastasia the Asian century but I think
the bigger question and I think what the
United States has been uncanny you know
my dad used to say this he said rich you
know when I signed up for the army but
remember the depression how down we were
and then when I signed up for the army
that we had Doughboy hats and these old
boots and they gave us broomsticks he
said the mobilization institutional
reheated say institutional resign the
mobilization for the war and the
factories got changed the government got
into it and boy we turned on a dime I am
puzzled as an American living in Canada
why we can't do this anymore why we're
so locked in is the word I think
economist would use and I don't know
what it's going to take to blow that up
but but the interesting thing is it's
not happening anywhere in the world it's
not like you click to China and say very
redesigning your institutions or Brazil
and say they're redesigning their
institutions it's almost as this
everyone is stuck in the same place it
seems to me that the mental models and
frameworks of the forest economy of the
mass production economy are so powerful
and so deeply ingrained in the way we
think it's hard to think in other terms
and so what I think happened actually is
people create their own safe space so
the folks in Silicon Valley said screw
that i'm not going to go try to rebuild
industrial for dizzam I'm going to carve
out a really cool thing here in Silicon
Valley for me you know I'm not going to
take this on and redo arts education I'm
going to build a little interesting arts
district in my community so I think
there's enough space and flexibility in
the system that people could find their
niche so
speak but I think the bigger question is
one of institutional redesign and and
and for folks you know listening in the
clock of history is always ticking it
doesn't stop so it's not like history
stops we've reached the end of history
in the last man the clock of history
text sooner or later some group of
people somewhere someplace will figure
this out and as they figure it out and
get this institutional redesign right
they'll get what huge advantage is
competitive advantage Jude's first mover
advantage and they'll eclipse us now I
still think we have a little time
because these are generational processes
but but somebody's got to wake up and
and and I'll hopefully hopefully it'll
happen soon hopefully that's what this
event were going through this economic
shock we're going through hopefully it
allow people to wake up and say these
are the new kinds of institutions first
we have to take down the old ones that
don't work anymore that's a big job and
secondly here are the new kinds of
institutions we have to build to make a
prosperous a more creative more
productive better society now you raise
an interesting comparison you talked
about China really r entering an era
where the cross national comparison is
going to be ever more apt and we're
going to be looking at best practices
across the world you said you really
don't see any emergence of these
approaches outside of the US will it be
you know do where do you expect it to
come from if not from from beyond that's
a great question I think there's one
place to look and it's not because I'm
interested in them I think in this
global world what we've minimized in
this idea that the world is becoming
global we're all becoming the same that
the world is flat we've minimized the
role of cities and this is why I've been
spending a lot of my time working on
cities not just because i love cities
but because i think they're important I
actually think they're the key
institutional actors you know in rise of
the creative class I said a couple
things I said one that place is coming
to replace the company as the key social
and organizing unit of the creative
economy its place that brings together
people its place that collects people
talented people ambitious people
whatever entrepreneurial people its
place that attaches us to work in a
mobile society and I said also that the
key struggles of our time would no
longer be fact
he struggles they would literally be
struggles about how our cities are used
who's moved around gentrification all of
those things are coming true but what I
think is really interesting is that if
you look at mayor's around the world you
know and the question I always ask is
why would somebody like in your hometown
somebody like Mike Bloomberg did you
remember the mayor's the people who used
to be mayor of New York right I'm for
nor where I grew up Cory Booker's the
mayor of newark now these were like
completely dysfunctional people who were
mayor's so you've got a whole new group
of people who are more business
sophisticated and in some ways let's not
even take the united states who do you
think's more powerful the Prime Minister
of England or the Mayor of London i'm
making a broad statement they may be
both very powerful people in China who
is really powerful the guy who runs
China or the mayor of Shanghai so the
mayor's have their hands on this really
interesting very powerful economic unit
and I think at the city level we're
beginning to see people ask these kinds
of deep questions what I worry about is
he's almost a disconnect and the other
thing that's so fascinating I can tell
you you could tell me anyone out there
could say the difference between a
Democrat and Republican a liberal and
conservative in a Congress or in a
parliament at the national level they're
like ideologically distinct people I go
to visit the city I meet a mayor
Democrat Republican liberal conservative
if I don't know i can't tell you know
what is Bloomberg what does cory booker
what is you know my friend John
Hickenlooper in Denver I don't know I
mean I guess I could go find out but
they all seem very Adrian Fenty in
Washington DC they're all very similar
and it's not ideologically driven it's
about making the city work pragmatically
so i think the real place to look for
these best practices it's at the city
level and you know this the cities are
probably the place is doing the most for
the environment and we know that they're
environmentally dense cities are
environmentally better anyway they're
making because they have two big
advances in education in retooling your
school systems they're the right place
to do productivity policy or economic
policy not at the federal level because
they're closer to the action so I think
the place to look is at the city level
and I think maybe maybe as much as we
need G to write the China in the US and
Lena the g8 we need a g20 maybe what we
really need is to get some of these
mayor's involved in the dialogue and
begin to learn not from everything
they've done but but some of the best
examples and I think the federal
government's the national governments
would be well served by saying look
we've got companies out there we can tap
we've got workers in union organizations
we can tab for invasion but these mayors
and these cities are actually developing
in a very small way in a local way
programs and approaches that we should
take a look at now you mentioned a range
of really can't stand out mayor's my
Mayor Mike Bloomberg being one of them I
mean he's had a range of very
interesting programs one of which was
relevant to us and that right after the
economic crisis hit New York devastating
Wall Street he announced a range of
initiatives to incent on North
absolutely and so I'm curious are there
examples that already would qualify as
you would describe it as best practices
that you've seen that you can point to
specifically well our friends in the
states I come look at Toronto I mean
we're worse hang and that's why I so
glad you could come up here I mean I
think in Toronto the whole effort one to
stim entrepreneurship to to really
invest in the creative economy and that
is creating a backlash here we're
getting artists and musicians saying
hold on come on well I'm not a commodity
I'm an artist I don't know if I want and
this dialogue that's happening in this
city where we begin to see real estate
price appreciation because we have it
here again and people say no no wait we
have to go slow trying to figure out
this balance between entrepreneurial
action the nature of the development in
the city the engagement of creative
industries and creative people and find
a balance we're really concerned in
Toronto about mounting inequality now
that we don't have inequality like we
have in the United States but my God
we're beginning to see economic
segmentation people are very concerned
about this the thing about Toronto that
really blows my mind we are having
another mayor's race our current mayor
is a terrific mayor and he's the
spectacular guy and cares about this and
understands it we have two or three
candidates already with their hats in
the ring all of whom would be
spectacular mayors I mean it's like
there's three four people running for
mayor all who are equally smart and
engaged I but I think focusing on
entrepreneurship is one focusing on of
course on technology
that's been a big theme you know Mike
Porter and cluster building that's been
a big theme of urban economic
development now for a generation I think
this idea of getting creative people
engaged that we started to kick off my
team and I getting creative people
engaged getting them motivated getting
them involved in the economy a dealing
with urban inequality dealing with the
environment making a city that's
creative sustainable inclusive and just
I mean would be that is a not just a
city that's rich and one of the things
that we've been trying to do is figure
out other measures of economic activity
that are not just material goods so you
know everybody out there has heard about
happiness we've actually been measuring
the happiness not just of nations but of
cities and states cities and states that
have a bigger creative economy the
people are happier the role of diversity
I think this is a key 1 i've talked
about this till I'm blue in the face you
can't have a great city unless you're
open to diversity and everyone can
contribute we find that the other thing
that we've been looking at which is just
a mind blower I started to get
interested in health and I think part of
it is I saw I saw people my parents were
lifelong smokers my dad died of lung
cancer I hate those things I'm sorry I
saw people stopped smoking I've never
been a smoker but and I saw all these
people starting to lose weight right it
became a big thing you're going to lose
weight they're going to get in shape so
I advanced this little hypothesis what
if the shift to smoking and and away
from obesity what if this was something
that was being caused by the post
industrial economy itself not just
rising incomes what if we could try to
determine that healthier behavior
whether it's higher levels of
satisfaction in your life and with
everything but more no more smoking and
no more eating you know massive
quantities of fast food we've just been
doing this research but the results are
so mind-blowing in places that have more
of this creative economy that have nutri
did it and built it that it's more
robust have higher educated populations
more involvement in the creative
industries significantly lower rates of
obesity significantly lower lower rates
of smoking controlling for income and
economics so I think something is
happening in the places that do this to
go quite beyond and and the mayor's are
beginning we're beginning to get a
handle you might say no smoking policy
or the labeling of food
all of these little things you know a
good buddy of mine came back from
England he's a great economic developer
he actually runs the big economic
development organization for four North
America tax with the world but its main
lead us in Canada and he said you know
in our field economic development in
city development you used to have a big
Fisher or a big game hunter go out and
get that big auto plan to that big
convention center and that bring that
big spalt into town he said if you want
to do that go to China I mean it was the
most remarkable things that all the big
projects the big plans the big steel
mills there were going to be in charge
few want to do that go to China he said
what's so interesting about managing a
city now is it a bunch of little things
that we typically haven't thought about
making your creative industries better
making sure your artists and musicians
have support making sure the place is
beautiful and physically interesting to
people investing in parks and green
space making sure that entrepreneurs
right like Bloomberg's do we have the
supports they need into space the
affordable space Jane Jacobs said new
ideas require old buildings all of these
millions and zillions of little things
that are very locally rooted that
upgrade the capability of people and
that's a mind shift that's beginning to
happen in some cities now one of the
things that on this point that you've
said that I thought found very profound
and very unique in its perspective is on
the issue of gays and gay rights you
have said that this is perhaps one of
the most telling indicators of a city's
potential for economic prosperity
explain that idea and if you will would
you go so far as to say that this is
there is actually an economic dimension
to a lot of the social discussions
particularly taking place in us right
now well at the highest level I actually
think that when we look back on the
history of understanding economic growth
we're going to recognize of course the
techno revert solar want a Nobel Prize
for this idea that technology matters to
economic growth we're surely going to
understand more understanding now that
human capital knowledge accumulation
matters whether it's at glacier or Paul
Romer at Stanford that human capital
accumulation knowledge accumulation
Robert Lucas at Chicago I think what
we're going to finally understand is
that these things that we thought as
social and cultural characteristics
particularly with regard to openness to
diversity meritocracy that
I call them the 3 t's technology talent
intolerance this tolerance dimension is
social and cultural dimension is not
just something we do because it's right
and it's ethical and its moral and it's
right way to treat people we're going to
find that these social and cultural
factors really add a lot to economic
growth and it's not just the Protestant
ethic of thrift and hard work that max
vay Bohr identified a century ago it's
actually I think what made America great
at the great american century was this
idea that people could come from all
over the world and make a life they want
have a dream that they wanted do the
kind of work and with regard without
regard to ethnicity so one of the things
that we found of course when we look at
the history of American entrepreneurship
there are lots of foreign-born people
whether it's andrew carnegie and steel
or Andy Grove the great semiconductor
inventor at Intel or anyone in the
high-tech you know vivek wadhwa and
Annalee saxenian did this great study
where they looked at Silicon Valley and
found that between a third and fifty
percent of all those companies were
founded by somebody who wasn't born in
the United States well the thing with
gays was really interesting to me I was
working on this at Carnegie Mellon just
minding my little old business trying to
study the knowledge economy and how
cities compete and the role of quality
of plates factors and artists and there
was a young man who was completing his
ph.d name's Gary gates he's now at the
williams institute at UCLA and my dean
at the time kept saying you should meet
Gary gates I was coming back from
sabbatical at Harvard you should meet
Gary gates is a great guy he's been
studying the location patterns of gay
men and why they're clustered in San
Francisco what he is finding is that gay
men in San Francisco have effect or the
related to amenities quality of life a
nice plays and so it's over you're
seeing the same thing with your
high-tech people so i went to be Gary
one day and as I've learned if you work
in this kind of socially I don't know
hot button area cultural hot button area
there's a lot of debate dialog you have
to develop a sense of humor so gary said
rich let me see your list of your
high-tech mecca's and of course it was
the San Francisco Bay Area in Silicon
Valley it was Austin Texas it was Boston
at we Seattle to San Diego Donna he's
like you just named five of the ten
gayest places in America so we left
hysterically and and in my old New
Jersey language wouldn't it be a great
goof what's the kind of way we in it
would it be a great goof
look at this was a joke well sorry
she's my friend we took a look at the
data and Gary is a fabulous statistician
and demographer and the more we looked
at the data the more it became clear
that there was an association now I've
never seen any of my empirical work
subject to this kind of scrutiny well
the association is spurious well the
association is causal you didn't have
instrumental variables we said right off
the bat it's not predictive it's not
that gay men are leading high-tech
businesses and then the thing that
landed me on colbert with a young woman
named charlotta melander is Swedish
young woman we actually looked at the
role of artists concentrations gay male
and lesbian concentration on housing
prices and what we found is controlling
for income controlling for education the
effect of this gay and lesbian arts
culture thing was G norma's but what is
going on so so places that are more open
places that value people that are more
meritocratic they're going to attract
more people with skill and ambition and
entrepreneurial Verve it's like it's
almost like an instrument the gay and
lesbian factor is approximate variable
for a place that's very open-minded and
self expressive a place the creative
person we know one thing about them they
want a self express they want whether
they're Andy Warhol or Bill Gates John
Lennon or Mick Jagger they want to
express themselves which deep within
them so places that allow you to do that
that activate that that allow you to
mobilize resources there are also the
places that are going to gain gain an
upper edge in the entrepreneurial and
innovative realm so that's what we found
and i'll tell you the kick back to that
i've never been exposed to this kind of
ricochet effect where people want to rip
this effect to shreds and i think it
reflects the fact that's a hot-button
issue but but we think we shed some
lightning we think now newer generations
of economist this young man named Scott
cage at Michigan has written a whole
book on diversity what he has concluded
theoretically is if you want to get a
new idea innovation you need cognitive
diversity demographic diversity a mixing
of people is a great proxy and a great
way to get cognitive diversity now let's
look at this from the perspective of
businesses because they're a big player
in all of this as they look at these
realities they look at you know
the theory that cities are going to
thrive more when they're more diverse
and more open-minded that they provide
these amenities and so forth what should
they be taking into account as they
tried to position themselves to be
magnets for creative talent well the
first thing for all you business folks
listening in or viewing I actually wrote
a lot on this I wrote the whole middle
section of rise of the creative class
deals with how business can compete and
then can harness and mobilize creative
talent so take a look at it I actually
wrote a piece with Jim goodnight a
Harvard Business Review looking at the
SAS Institute but I think for business
this ability to attract talent and the
companies that are doing this this is
best practice the companies that are
attracting people globally that are
putting in place diversity efforts and
you know we I've gotten to speak to a
number of these companies and see what
they're up to that's clearly the wave of
the future it now don't get me wrong I
want to be really honest whether there's
a city out there or a company that can
harness one ethnic group or one racial
group that could develop a niche in that
you know if they're religiously oriented
come up an example of a city or a
company that's more homogeneous that's
quite successful but in general in
general the advantage you get from
open-mindedness and diversity and
meritocracy and being inclusive and and
I think most importantly allowing what
the real key to the creative ages
allowing people to self-express allowing
people to be themselves and not have to
be this facsimile of a person a company
man if you will accompany person I think
create it you know I said in rise of the
creative class it's not like you can
pump creativity out of someone or speed
up the assembly line of creativity
people can easily withhold their
creativity so if you're not motivating
them internally if you're not motivating
them intrinsically if you're not
allowing them to self-express they'll
just shut down and they'll use their
creativity at night or on their off time
that's really the thing so companies
it's not feed or Drucker said you're no
longer going to be able to motivate
these creative people with money you
have to treat them as volunteers I can't
allow them self-express that's where
companies have to get to and I think the
best companies the biggest global
companies
see that now we've got some questions
from the audience which have come in
awesome yeah sir which have come in
through Twitter so let me hit some of
these while we've got some time left
this is from nem multimedia he or she
writes how do we create a society that
values the creativity of every person
for the good of that society that's our
end game right and that that's my end
game and you know what the first thing
you have to do i think is education and
it's speaking and evangelism and you
have to get out there and make the case
and show facts the other thing I think
we have to do is what this person did
one of the things that I find always
happens to me is people see the word
creative class and they say oh my God
he's talking about a creative elite
either an artistic and lead or a
technologically depending upon who but
in all my work I've said every human
being is creative what we have to do is
include everyone in this creative class
and i think so that's a continuous
message that it's not just about
supporting a creative a lead and unequal
society it's about harnessing enhancing
this thing that every human being shares
every human being shares every child has
intrinsically this ability to be
creative and then showing how we're not
going to grow our economy we're not
going to be prosperous we're not going
to develop our people allow them to have
helped happy and fulfilled vibes unless
they can't you know I think the other
part of this look at the giant
consumption and shopping binge that we
just went through what is that about you
know I'm going to buy my identity and a
designer rack you know and you look at
these young gals the young Hollywood
gals and literally a label on every part
of their Anatomy embody than the right
car that's because people can't find
purpose right and I think what what what
what we really do is we don't create
ourselves simply through consumption I
don't want to be anti consumption my dad
was really happy when he bought a new
Chevy I'm telling you and he whacks that
thing in there was pure joy in the guy's
eyes when he got a new Chevy but but
port giving purpose in their lives and
giving people purpose I certainly felt a
lot better in my own life when I found a
purpose you know then when I was a young
kid you know trying to play music or
trying to get through school I found a
purpose i could write i could make a
difference and i think most people that
you talk to write most people you might
interview when they find their purpose
it creates an enormous well-being
that's what psychologists of creativity
and fulfillment tell us imagine if we
could give that gift to more people but
not just to give them the gift I think
giving them that gift is self-express
and be creative is actually the economic
pump prime times the pump it creates
more innovation it creates more
entrepreneurship it gets people ignited
and excited and I think that's where we
have to go now our next question is from
behance team and I like this question
and that keys off something you said
earlier they asked how would you
incorporate crowdsourcing to develop the
creative class and this actually reminds
me of you talking about how companies
are using their employees as a source of
information can these tools these
information technology tools
particularly that allow crowdsourcing
play a part in in developing both the
creative class and and also the service
so i'm back to first principles marks
told us in his most brilliant insight
when he was talking about how classes
form in the working class all labor is
inner subjective now a big fancy term
for saying we all depend on one another
you can't make anything without any
talked about science and scientists what
do you do it's dead labor and living
labor any scientist will tell you we
stand on the shoulder of giants we stand
on the shoulders of all those who came
before us and not only our team and all
those who are round and so whether it's
factory production whether it's services
whether it's agriculture its inner
subjective it's team-based this whole
idea that invention finally we're
getting over this that there's a great
genius around the great genius was
always a fabulous Thomas Edison the fat
the first person to really build a team
in a lab of technicians and chemist and
machinists that support his ideas now we
know that many people have these ideas
so the wisdom of the crowd crowd
sourcing is key we have to tap this is
what Toyota told me I went to visit
Toyota when I was studying manufacturing
about 1985 and I went to their factory
complex in Toyota city in Japan the guy
told me professor Florida we're going to
beat the big three this is like 1985
1960 86 why you think the key to success
in your management in the West is the
bigshot CEO Lee Iacocca right with all
the great ideas ramming it for the
bureaucracy turn around then
flanked by two MBAs and a great research
the strategist he said we're going to
win because we have tens of thousands of
people on the factory floor and back
through our supply chain the crowd
that's going to harness this kind of
energy we're going to use their energy
their talent these millions and millions
of individuals so the technology I mean
is this incredible tool now that we have
and it's funny that the questions are
coming in from Twitter I mean Twitter
I've always been fascinating by the
internet i taught at carnegie mellon i
was an early adopter nothing has
fascinated me more than twitter for the
ability to harness other people's
information but to get direct access to
people i thought i could never talk to
and so i think the technology provides
another enabling infrastructure and i
think the other thing not only enables
us to tap into the wisdom of the crowd
it also enables individuals to mobilize
for sources so you have almost the crowd
at your disposal as an individual and as
ideas become good they can mobilize
people both consumers and workers so I
think the technology is part it's almost
like the railroad right the canal system
was a technology of one error the
railroad was a technology and
infrastructure of another area that a
highway system this thing and it's not
just the internet this ability to use
social media and mobilize intelligence
I've never seen anything like it and
just from a work point of view my
ability to collaborate and work with
people I don't even remember and i'm
sure most of us I don't even remember
how I could have worked before the
efficiency gains and the innovation
gains are just so dramatic next question
is from yen he asked what problems would
be good for the creative class to solve
an accompanied I guess is there a
specific set of advantages or challenges
that the creative class is uniquely able
to confront within a company well you
know it's funny getting across those
borders not just staying in your lab but
going to the factory floor what I was
thinking about the companies that have
applied creative energy to products to
appliances it's those kinds of things
taking it into services agriculture the
development of new and better food
products the revolution of food chains
as whole Michael Pollan thing that's
where I think the real interesting
problems are in society and then
ultimately i think the local
so I think for companies to really
realize how important their city or
their community is and one of the things
i think that creative people are very
attuned to is how important their local
environment in who's your city i wrote
this there are three big things that
lead make us have a happy life one is
the work we do the challenging exciting
work not money money is important
they'll get me wrong but it's a
challenging work we do and the way we
get purpose from that of course it's our
social relationships our families but
the love that's in our life and personal
relationships but the third piece that
we always forget is the place we live is
an important part of that so I think for
companies thinking a lot more not only
about the products they make that the
places where they're based and actively
because the people what I interviewed
creative people they said I'd really
love my work but I'd actually like to
spend more time not only at home I'd
like to spend more time making my place
better I'd like to volunteer and be
involved in boards and all of this sort
of thing I think that's another area and
I you know and also in development of
technology and development with products
you know IBM and lots of companies are
getting into smart cities other
companies are getting into green
technology I think a big opportunity
creative opportunity are actually how do
you remake locations and make them not
only more creative but more inclusive
and sustainable so that's that's a
couple places at least to focus now you
actually hit on the next question of
pretty squarely which was basically how
do companies provide what what can they
provide for the creative class that's
going to attract them and make them want
to you know activate their talents on
its behalf you mentioned a few there are
there others well I think the mistake
that cities or companies make and I
think sometimes in my name so oh my god
we put in you know a new arts district
the arts district with the the cool loft
spaces is going to attract the creative
class of company says oh my god you know
we decided and we you know we outfitted
we created open space and open layout
we've got a great architect in here and
we have new modern furniture and we have
you know pinball machines and jolt cola
and an espresso bar and that's going to
do it that's cool that's cute that I
think the real thing that people want is
the ability to be themselves itself
Express that's really the key thing how
does a company or a city figure out how
to allow its people to be themselves to
self-express to engage in projects that
they find exciting
and channel that energy so it seems to
me that's the core driver everything
else kind of has to be tuned to that and
and for the members of the creative
class for those of us who have a lot of
choice in what we do and where we do it
I think what we're really trying to find
I've been looking at this with a
fabulous young psychologist named Jason
Renfro jason is a Cambridge and he was
the first person like one thing Jason
figured out is that you didn't have to
do a personality assessment you could
just look at somebody's ipod playlist
and you can completely read their
personality what Jason and I have been
looking at is the location of
personality types and you know they're
five basic personality types right
there's agreeable people just
conscientious people there's extroverts
there's emotionally stable or neurotic
people then there's these people called
open to experience if you look at
entrepreneurs whether it's Bill Gates or
Steve Jobs if you look at great artists
or musicians chances are they're very
very high on this dimension called open
to experience open to experience get
their charge in life by consuming new
experiences by understanding the
experiences and what we're finding is
that those people are highly mobile and
it's not like I say to myself I'm open
to experience I want to find and open to
experience neighborhood these people
find some way by hook or by crook they
leave their home town and they find the
places whether that's the same francisco
bay area or silicon valley or a part of
lower east side or cell phone York or
wherever it is at the moment because
these places chef right there exciting
for a moment then they go down these
open to experience people what we find
is they're highly clustered in cities
highly clustered near the core of cities
and highly clustered in particular
cities and and so I think what they're
searching for is not just a great place
with a great scene in great espresso
bars and great loft flats but they're
searching for is a place where they can
be themselves be surrounded by other
experiential people and other things and
that becomes a stimulus to their their
endeavors well on that note that very
big and profound note Richard I want to
thank you for joining us and I want to
thank the audience for joining us again
I am Peter Hopkins from big pink calm
and this was a special live interview
with bestselling author Richard Florida
thank you thank you Richard watchu yeah
I was great we're turning really awesome
you know and
you